affection or compassionate attitude or
hardness there is very very important
for one's own well-being I think the
number one thing to do is to build the
mini dream first if you try to control
the variety of situations that may pop
up in your face tomorrow morning all
that will happen is you will become a
very limited life wanna be happy build a
life not just a business
[Music]
every single day
hates every Carmichael and this channel
was created to help you overcome the
number one challenge that is holding you
back a lack of belief in yourself you
watch these videos because you know
there's something more inside you too
you've got Michael Jordan level talent
at something so today let's live your
best believe life and learn five
life-changing piece of advice from monks
and gurus
okay let's kick it off with lesson
number one have compassion with the
Dalai Lama affection of compassionate
attitude warm-heartedness there is very
very important for one's own well-being
one's own happiness so don't consider
practice of compassion is something
release matter or practice of compassion
is something good for other not
necessarily to oneself that's a totally
mistake so since from childhood we
already equipped this seed of compassion
we learned from mother and ourself in
order to become parent the deceit
already there now that's it you must
keep natural whole our life the
biological factor compassion is limited
biased and more depend on others
attitude now dad as a seed
then using reasons awareness dad seed
compassion or can develop can further
develop unbiased a compassion not based
on not depend on others attitude but
the others being itself so that kind of
compassion can reach your enemy or
entire sentient being so that compassion
is infinite compassion unbiased
compassion real compassion so if we
become compassionate person then your
life becomes meaningful because you
yourself happy come peacefully your
friend or including animals also you get
peace so at the last day of our life
you'll feel happy now hold my life now
spend peaceful friendly feel happy
otherwise at that moment even your be
linear those money nothing can be used
no matter what so good because of a good
body or beautiful body all everything
have to doesn't have to leave so at that
time I think Jenny's affection can bring
if your whole life spend more
compassionate life than you feel or know
the planet so the bus of life is
naturally happy life meaningful life so
in order to make meaningful life
ultimately ohm hardness is the key
factor lesson number two build the mini
dream first with Jay Shetty how do you
know your dream is your dream how do you
go after something
you don't know if it's actually meant
for you or not great question I think
the number one thing to do is to build
the mini dream first so before trying to
go off on this huge journey of building
this humongous dream build the mini
version of it and see what it feels like
so if you want to be someone who travels
across the world and performs travel to
one city and perform if you want to be
someone who's in movies go and film a
short movie write like go and build the
mini version of that dream because that
many dreams gonna teach you so much like
I'll give you an example I know so many
people who say to me I want to be an
actor and I'll be like okay great well
let's make a short movie and when they
make a short movie and they realize
they're up at 5 a.m. every day and that
they're in the studio or on a set to
10:00 p.m. and they realize this set is
not very glamorous that they realize
they have to say the same line 30 times
before the director says that line is
okay if you lasted only actors anymore
because what we've fallen in love with
is what the dream looks like and not
what the dream is so my biggest advice
to anyone including myself has always
been build the mini dream and the mini
dream will teach you everything you need
to know about whether you're ready for
the big dream it's the same as sports if
you want to be a sports player wake up
at 4 a.m. every day go to the gym for
two hours a day like do the actual
schedule do the actual process of the
person who's already doing it so I
always say look at what people were
doing when they were at your age not on
the stage there right now and do that
and see whether you love that that's how
you figure it out it's just been a very
small level also if you want to have
more self-love motivation and confidence
check out my 254 series they're free the
link to join are in the description
below the quality of your life is
essentially determined by how you
carried this one yes or no no one on
planet earth can stop you from
accomplishing and achieving what you
want it's easy to make a buck very hard
to make a difference lesson number three
set clear goals with dhandapani
a monk that tells you he's never
questioned the path
a thought of leaving is lying to you
even though I wanted to be amongst
incest fault I thought many times of
leaving and not wanting to do it but use
a stick to it because that's what you
love it's I'm sure when you're running
the race at that point I wanna quit
every race I do all right
it's crazy yeah we got everything I get
it yeah
so it's the same way as well that's just
the thought comes up and you just go
like but this is what this is you right
you're the racing this you being being
one kiss me there's a little crickets
that get in your head and those crickets
are telling you right you're on the
wrong path and you've gotta get rid of
them
yeah and it's I think it's just being
crystal clear of what you want in life
right from the start yeah and then just
having their willpower and the
perseverance to to follow it through and
be unwavering in that in your commitment
and your TrueNorth and yeah where do you
want to go well you know I think they
yeah I think most people get swayed is
because they don't really know what they
want in life and if you ask most people
what they want in life to say I want to
be happy and happiness is not a goal a
presidency at all yeah it's a byproduct
of something right if if I eat ice cream
or drink here I might feel happy but
it's not a goal to be pursued and I
think that's why people get off the pass
so often is because they don't know
where they're going
lesson number four be well managed with
Satguru if you try to control the
variety of situations that may pop up in
your face tomorrow morning all that will
happen is you will become a very limited
life you would step out into the world
and do whatever that needs to be done
only if you have an assurance no matter
what you walk into you will not lose
yourself you will walk full stride
otherwise you'll only be a half a step
most human beings are half steps because
the fear of suffering if this happens
what will happen to me that happens what
will happen to me if you're well managed
within yourself you know how to manage
your thought you know how to manage your
emotion you know how to manage your body
your chemistry your energy if you know
how to manage all this what does it
matter if you walk into hell I'm asking
if you are well managed if you are a
heaven
within you what does it matter where you
go he'll also will be an interesting
place to go but if you are ill managed
then you want to be in a nice place all
the time you will not step out into
anything I am NOT saying this is wrong
this is against nature because in nature
every life is aspiring to a bee as much
as it can be isn't it
every life is naturally aspiring this is
not a philosophy this is not an ideology
but you must do this or that it is
natural and intrinsic for every life
that you will do as much as it can from
an earthworm from a worm to an insect to
a bird to an animal to a tree every one
of them are trying to be full-fledged
life if you go against this simply
because of the fear of suffering then
all possibilities of exploring the
nature of being human the tremendous
immensity of being human is just lost
upon humanity today you will see this
everywhere when people say I am only
human they are talking about the
limitations of being human they are not
talking about the possibilities of being
human isn't it when if we are the most
intelligent species on the planet if we
are the most capable species on the
planet should we be talking about our
possibilities or should we be talking
about our limitations
whenever anybody writes or says oh we
are human they are always referring to
their limitations never to the
possibilities of being human this is
because the the most fundamental things
have not been taught in our education
systems how to handle your thought and
your emotion your psychological drama
has gone out of control
it's a badly directed drama believe me
if it is a well directed drama you would
take it to the conclusion that you want
isn't it because it's a badly directed
drama just about anybody can take charge
of it who
is the director of your psychological
drama just about anybody isn't it
anybody can make it into your tragedy
and lesson number five the last one
before a very special bonus clip is walk
your own path with Google Paul das there
were five men who got lost in a wasp
forest and were trying to find their way
out the first man said I'm going to
follow my intuition and go to the left
the second man said I'm going to go a
right I have a strong feeling that
that's the way out
the third man said well I'm going to
walk back on the same path that we took
to reach here I think that would be the
safest the fourth man said I think we
are absolutely on the right track
already and so I'm going to keep walking
straight after the four men took to the
left the right back and straight
respectively the fifth man said well I
don't know what to do I think I'm just
going to climb up the store tree and get
a better view around before I make up my
mind from the top of the tree the fifth
man could now see what was the shortest
way to the village isn't it a fact that
when you rise above a situation and see
the larger picture your decision seems
to be the most sound well yes indeed
there's a slight twist
the story the fifth man thought that the
other should not have chosen the paths
they did and that he was right and they
were wrong and from one point of view he
was right but from another perspective
I'm not too sure each man had chosen his
own path and gained a different
experience it's not just about right or
wrong but about gaining your own
experience and finding your own path the
man who went left found a long path but
at the end well it led him to the town
the man who went right at the white a
pack of wolves
but then he learned how to survive in
the forest the man who went backwards
met another team of hikers and guess
what he made new friends the man who
went straight found a farm and was
hosted by the family for a couple of
days before leaving for the village and
of course the man on the tree found the
shortest path the journey enriched each
one of them
in their own unique way every decision
offers us new experiences which in turn
adds to our maturity understood
ultimately leading to our own growth
isn't it set but life is like an exam
people failed because it tried to copy
others not realizing that each one has a
different question paper a different
test
ladies and gentlemen walk your own path
while you also learn from the experience
of others now I have a special bonus
clip on how to transform suffering with
tick not Han that I think you're gonna
enjoy but before that it's time for the
three point landing questions let's go
from just watching a video to taking
action here we go question number one
what does walk in your own path mean to
you number two how can you have more
compassion in your life and number three
what does your first mini dream look
like and if you like this video and
promise you take action after watching
it give me a hashtag believe down in the
comments as well we don't just watch
videos here we do something about it so
give me a hashtag believe make that
promise to yourself and then get to work
people afraid of me being overwhelmed by
something and they lose the hope the
correlations there must be a way to live
in order for you to be strong enough in
order to
to handle a suffering inside of you and
if you don't know how to handle the
suffering inside of you you cannot help
another person to suffer less and that
is why the practice of mindfulness first
of all is to help you yourself to suffer
less first of all you have to learn how
to release the tension in your body how
to reduce the pain in your body and the
practice of mindful breathing mindful
walking sitting meditation total
relaxation can be very helpful in
reducing the pain in your body and then
with the practice of mindfulness you can
you can learn how to create we generate
a feeling of joy and hope and of
happiness of happiness and this can be
done by anyone if we want to learn
fountains when you breathe it and if you
focus your attention on your in-breath
and then you can bring your mind home to
your body
and there is the energy of mindfulness
concentration in your in-breath and you
realize that you are alive because
someone who is already dead doesn't
breathe in anymore
so one impress that my last three or
four seconds can create mindfulness
concentration and insight and when the
body and mind are together you are
established in the present moment in the
he and allow and you can get in touch
with the wonders of life that are
available in the here and now and with
that kind of mindfulness and
concentration you realize that you are
lucky enough luckier than many people
you have enough conditions to be happy
right now right here and you don't have
to run into the future to look for
happiness and that happens after three
or four seconds or practice of mindful
breathing you get the insight that there
are conditions of happiness that are
available in the here and now
you are very lucky your life inside can
can happen just after a few seconds of
practice and the fact that you can
recognize and embrace your pain can
bring you a relief because the pain is a
kind of energy and mindfulness is
another kind of energy this energy
embracing the other energy will make
produce a kind of change like a mother
holding her baby the baby suffers the
mother does not know yet what is the
cause of the suffering of the baby but
the fact that is she's holding the baby
turnery can make the baby suffer less
right away because that there is the
energy of tenderness from the mother
penetrating into the body of the baby
that that bring relief and if she
continues with my fall holding and she
will find out the course that make the
baby suffer and then kisses she can
change the situation
if you want to know the monk secrets
that will change your life check out the
video right there next to me I think
you'll enjoy it continue to believe and
I'll see you there through the power of
mantra affirmation you can actually
shape and create patterns within your
mind so then we fully shall develop